if we look at your parents mail I looked
at one piece of mail it said his name
it's a Salvatore nun Maniscalco I said
that what is this exam the application
asks me for my middle name
I put nun Sebastian Maniscalco from date
Hungary it says latest Netflix special
and just one of his recent achievements
he sold out shows at Madison Square
Garden he's been in an oscar-winning
movies written a book well now he's
starring in the Irishman with Robert De
Niro and Al Pacino Jamie Wax caught up
with him to talk about his continued
rise Jamie he's got a lot going on he
certainly does Michelle good morning
it's been a good year for Sebastian to
say the least I spent time with him in
several venues most recently at one of
his favorite restaurants to talk about
his career his family and where it all
began
Sebastian Maniscalco has been steadily
gaining fans for years
unbelievable walking through the
backstage area of Madison Square Garden
with you
and now his sharply hilarious
observations about the annoying truths
of modern life I've been all over the
world Egypt Lebanon Beirut I've been all
over the security in their airports
unbelievable all military neat hats
machine guns punctuated with his
signature bits of physical comedy have
you seen our first line of the fun
he says you see the first guy they send
out picked out your laptop
have brought him to the very top of the
stand up world this appear stand up you
and your ideas
selling out this place almost 20,000
people what does that feel like
personally I'm from Chicago so is
watching Michael Jordan and the playoff
games in the Knicks all playing on the
floor here and now you know it's mine
for two nights yes it's pretty cool
you're Michael Jordan moment my Michael
Jordan moment yeah
selling out four shows at America's most
famous arena is a huge achievement for
any company but it's one Maniscalco earn
one standard performance at a time it's
a different feeling when your doorbell
rings today opposed to 20 years ago
right 20 years ago your doorbell rang
that was a happy moment in your house
it's called company this level of
success did not come early in your life
or overnight it was ten years at the
comedy clubs you know just grinding and
and after the show I would meet the
people after the show and take photos
and kind of make that connection with
every one of my fans for Maniscalco it
all started back in 1995 when he was a
college student and took the stage for a
campus contest
why not I did like seven minutes died
completely just an awful my parents came
up it wasn't good but I knew that's what
I wanted to do hi congratulations I'm
here to test your daughter's hearing and
my wife's like oh yeah come on in I said
what are you talking about hearing she's
two hours old what is my daughter gonna
do
for many years before his success the
comedian waited tables at the Four
Seasons in Los Angeles
while sharpening his skills at nearby
clubs what I've learned is there's no
substitute for you know dedication hard
work and patience I want to take a photo
with my father and everybody here if
that would that would be great I love
you dad
that work ethic instilled in him by his
father helped bring him from small clubs
to the entertainment world's biggest
venues I just got a card from him
recently and the first half of the card
was oh I'm so proud of you so fantastic
what you accomplished then the second
half for the car was you got to stay
hungry you got to keep going I mean he
would think that I didn't do anything
you couldn't really have imagined the
career you have now even in your wildest
dreams while you're working at the Four
Seasons here I knew I was going to make
it if you don't believe that then why
are you here so but I just didn't know
to what extent it was going to go to I I
had confidence in my ability to make
people laugh it was just one of these
things where I didn't have a TV career I
didn't have a film career to kind of
propel my standup that situation has
changed big time as his success has gone
way beyond stand-up
this year alone Maniscalco hosted the
MTV Video Music Awards
nice huh beautiful and had a role in the
Best Picture Oscar winner Green Book
no he had a great job at the Sanitation
Department you shouldn't have punched
out the formant woke me up you really
believe in that big now he can be seen
on the big screen again
alongside some of Hollywood's most
acclaimed actors working with one of its
most celebrated the rounders would you
say that's right thank you Jim why not
dick Rickles is you oughta make jokes
Vince applause the Irish directed by
Scorsese starring Pacino De Niro Harvey
Keitel unbelievable cast and Sebastian
Maniscalco gallows yeah it's it's crazy
when I when I got this role for this
movie I was really nervous because I
don't do a lot of acting we're brothers
right that's right
so brothers brothers you're brothers you
would have told me this in 1998 that I
would be in a movie with all these guys
I would have said hey this movie will
probably never get made and be you know
why would I be in it but here we are but
that doesn't mean he's lost all fear in
fact he says it provides some major
motivation
I feel if I'm not nervous or I'm not
like anxious then I'm going to fail
give me Michelangelo yeah it's a fear
base that's never positive if I'm not
frightened then I'm not gonna do good
Maniscalco says what keeps him grounded
amidst all that fear and success is
being husband to wife Lana and father to
their two children still the pull of
that work ethic is always on his mind
you know I've been off for about a month
now I'm kind of chomping at the bit to
kind of get back on the road not that I
don't like hanging out at the house but
I feel like my whole being is
work-related
I don't feel whole unless some working
you
have been great this has been one
fantastic evening thank you so so much
New York City thank you up there you can
go see Sebastian live now on his new you
bother me tour and the Irishman is
currently fathered me that's right the
Irishman has planted select theaters and
will be available on Netflix November
27th getting some great reviews why do I
feel like I can I can I can imitate him
at that same level of annoyance with
things you get annoyed like the
Sebastian does and then you make it fun
I think there's been multiple drinks
yeah I mean I think this has gone way
beyond what he saw for himself yeah put
the work in and paid off oh really good
nice job James
thank you